I mean the sign bite answer is you
should be moral because in the long run
looking at your real interests it will
be better for you when you look at
people like Madoff and so on or going
back to earlier similar crises why do
these people who already have so much
money sacrifice ethical standards in
order to have more that's the
bewildering thing and I think it has to
be that they have the wrong view of
their self-interest they actually
believe that the difference between
having 10 million and and a billion is
some are a really important difference
that is going to make their lives so
much better and is worth taking risks
for because they must have known they
were taking serious risk and I think
that's that's a mistake I don't think
there's any evidence that suggests that
you're necessarily going to be happier
as a billionaire then once you've got 10
million 10 million
I think the major difference between my
views when I was just a graduate student
and now is I give more weight to the
idea that you can give a an answer from
the perspective of enlightened
self-interest to the question why should
I be moral so it I think it's very often
not always but it's very often in our
interest to have ethical standards and
to act in accordance with them and
that's that's good for us in our
relations with others because people
respect us because of it and get to know
it it's also good for us in terms of our
sense of satisfaction and fulfillment
with life and so I think that you can
give an answer that works well for many
people if not quite perfectly through
that and I didn't really I wasn't really
as aware of that when I wrote the the
master's thesis but in the other other
respects the rest of the thesis I think
I would probably still accept I don't
think you can rationally prove an answer
for everyone irrespective of their
nature and their preferences that shows
that it's always rational for the trait
you